WERE WAITING FOR QUORUM BUT
WE'LL GO WE CAN BEGIN AS A
COMMITTEE.
AND AS SOME OF YOU KNOW -- WE
HAVE A LOT OF MEMBERS THAT ARE
IN DOUBLE COMMITTEES AND THOSE
KINDS OF THINGS OR HOPING THAT.
THEY WILL COME -- SOON AS THE
SERGEANTS HAVE CALLED THEM SO
WE'RE HOPING THAT THEY WILL BE
HERE SOON SO WE CAN GET A QUORUM
TO BECAUSE WE HAVE SOME VOTE ON
ITEMS.
AS WELL AS SOME COMMITTEE ITEMS
AND THEN SOME MEMBER ITEMS -- IN --
WE HAVE AGREED AT LEAST I HAVE
AGREED TO HEAR MEMBER ITEMS --
AND BECAUSE MANY COMMITTEES
DON'T DO THAT IS JUST SIMPLY GET
THE LETTER AND HE AND AND
RESPOND TO IT SO WE WILL BE
HEARING MEMBER ITEMS AND SO I DO
HAVE A MEMBER HERE.
I'M GOING TO LET HIM PRESENT HIS
BILL SO THAT HE DOESN'T HAVE TO
SIT THROUGH ALL THE OTHERS AND
OF COURSE BECAUSE HE'S HERE AND
ON TIME I'M SMILING ON HIS
PROPOSAL.
OF OF MEMBER KANSEN CHU COMMON
IT UP YOU HAVE TO ITEMS ONE AN
AUTO KERR THEFT IN BREAKING AN
ITEM AND THE SAN JOSE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS.
WE'RE ASKING THAT YOU CAN FIND
YOURSELF TO FIVE MINUTES OF
CONVERSATION WITH US THANK YOU
SO MUCH.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH ABOUT THE
WHOEVER -- PERSON.
AND AND A MEMBER FIVE WILL NOT
PASS ON THE OPPORTUNITY -- TO
PROCESS. TO ALL OF MY VERY
IMPORTANT BILLS AND THIS --
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
OF OF FIRST ONE IS THE A TWO OUT
FOR COMMITTEE FOR A ONE TIME
FUNDING FORCE SOME HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND WHAT EACH OF THE POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN MY DISTRICT. TO
ADDRESS THE CAR BREAKING IN AND
THEFT FROM BETTER COLES I'LL
HOLD WELL ONE OF THE THANK THE A
YOUR STAFF FOR WORKING WITH MY
OFFICE.
ON THIS ISSUE -- DESTRUCTIVE SIX
IN MY TO THE CITIES ARE
STARTLING.
THE NEWARK POLICE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED A ROUGHLY A 30%
INCREASE FROM.
TWENTY FIFTEEN TO TWENTY
EIGHTEEN M. PROJECT THAT 93%
INCREASE IN TWENTY NINETEEN DUE
TO THE HIGH NUMBER OF INCIDENTS
SINGS.
FROM JANUARY TO FEBRUARY.
THIS HOUSE A PD REPORTED A 14%
INCREASE IN THE SAME PERIOD.
SB SIX THOUSAND SEVEN HUNDRED
TWENTY ONE CASES IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN ADDITIONALLY THE
FREMONT POLICE DEPARTMENT
REPORTED A 27% INCREASE AS WELL.
THE PEOPLE LIVING IN MY DISTRICT
LOVE WAS DAILY FEAR.
OF BEING IN A VICTIM WHETHER
THEY ARE SHOPPING VISITING
FRIENDS OR GOING TO POST OFFICES.
THE CRYING MIND SEEMS MINOR
COMPARED TO OTHERS.
BUT IT REALLY AFFECT THE QUALITY
OF LIFE AND ESPECIALLY THOSE WHO
ARE WORKING HARD TO JUST STAYED
AHEAD.
A BROKEN WINDOW WILL MEAN COST.
TO REPAIR AND PROBABLY INCREASE
IN A MONTHLY INSURANCE FEE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY TO SPEAK IN
SUPPORT IS OUR VICE MAYOR FROM
SAN JOSE.
MR CHOPPY JONES.
THANK YOU AUDIBLE CHEER IN
MEMBERS -- IN THANK YOU ASSEMBLY
MEMBER I KANSEN CHU FOR
RECOGNIZING THE IMPORTANT NEED
FOR FUNDING -- TO LOCAL BUT
POLICE DEPARTMENTS TO COMBAT.
THE RISE IN PROPERTY CRIMES -- I
HAD A MEETING WITH THAT HAVE HAD
A SMALL NEIGHBORHOOD NOT
SHOPPING CENTER.
EARLY ON FRIDAY IT WAS YOUR
TYPICAL -- LITTLE NEIGHBORHOOD.
RESTAURANTS IN FITNESS CENTERS
AND THEY PRESENTED ME WITH --
SOME STATISTICS FROM THIS SMALL
NEIGHBORHOOD SHOPPING CENTER THE
PAST TWENTY EIGHT DAYS THEY HAD
TWENTY FOUR REPORTED INSTANCES
CONSISTING OF CAR BURGLARY.
VANDALISM LARCENY AND CAR THEFT.
OVER THE PAST HUNDRED EIGHTY
DAYS.
THEY HAD A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
NINE REPORTED INCIDENTS
CONSISTING OF CARBERY.
VANDALISM LARCENY.
DRUG VIOLATIONS IN CART THAT.
THIS IS A CONVERSATION I JUST
HAD ON FRIDAY.
AND YOU KNOW THE MOST
DISHEARTENING PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION AS I HAD TO SPEND A
LARGE PART OF THAT CONVERSATION.
SETTING THEIR EXPECTATIONS OF
WHAT WE COULDN'T DO.
AND HOW WE COULDN'T SUPPORT THEM
THE WAY WE WANT.
TO AND I WALKED AWAY FROM THAT
MEETING -- WITHOUT A CLEAR
RECOGNITION THAT.
WE HAVE TO DO BETTER AND THAT'S
WHY I COMMEND THEM ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
CHIU FOR HIS -- HIS BILL AND I
WHOLEHEARTEDLY.
REQUEST THAT YOU SUPPORT THAT.
THANK YOU -- ANY OF THE ME TUNES
IN THE AUDIENCE JUST TO SAY YOUR
NAME AND THAT YOU AGREE.
YOU CAN GO FORWARD THERE'S A
MICROPHONE DOWN FRONT.
JUST TO GIVE YOU A NAME IF YOU
WITH AN AGENCY AND JUST SAY YOU
KNOW BASICALLY ME TOO I AGREE.
ME TOO I AGREE -- COUNCILMEMBER
SOVIET AND US FROM THE CITY OF
SAN JOSE THANKS.
OKAY ANYONE ELSE.
RIGHT THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS OF
MS.
TO TWO NO OKAY FINE THANK YOU
YOU'RE PROPOSAL'S RADICALLY YOU
HAVE ANOTHER ONE WITH BEFORE US
NOW YES MA'AM OKAY.
AND AGAIN THANK YOU VERY MUCH
TODAY I'M ALSO HERE TO PRESENT
THE COMMITTEE. FOR A TWELVE
MILLION DOLLARS TO FUND
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS AND
HAZARD MITIGATION.
IN THE CITY OF SAN JOSE.
THIS FUNDING WILL BE USED TO
SUPPORT SOUTH FACING EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT PREPAREDNESS
READINESS AND RECEIVE LIAM THE
PROGRAM.
THIS INCLUDE TRAINING AND
RECORDING STAFF CONDUCTING
MITIGATION PROJECT RETROFITTING
BUILDINGS AND SUPPORTING
PLANNING NEEDS.
THERE'S NO QUESTION THAT THE
POTENTIAL FOR DISASTER IN
CALIFORNIA IS INCREASING.
AND THAT WE NEED TO BE PREPARED
FOR THIS.
IN FACT THEY HAVE BEEN TWELVE
PRESIDENTIAL MAJOR DISASTER
DECLARATION IN CALIFORNIA THINGS.
TWENTY THIRTEEN LOCALLY IN
FEBRUARY FEBRUARY TWENTY
SEVENTEEN SAN JOSE EXPERIENCED
EXTREME FLOODING F. COYOTE CREEK.
DEAD RESOLVED IN THE FALL FIFTY
MILLION DOLLARS IN DAMAGES.
UNFORTUNATELY THE OHM
PREDICTABLE FLOW OF FEDERAL
FUNDS AND THE LACK OF A STABLE
STATEWIDE FUNDING SYSTEM HINDER
LOCAL GOVERNMENTS ABILITY TO
HAVE COMPREHENSIVE EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM.
SO SAY IS COMMITTED. TO BRINGING
<c.red>N -- TO BE READY TO MITIGATE</c>
AND RESPONSE TO EMERGENCIES BUT
NEED FURTHER SUPPORT IN ORDER.
TO ACHIEVE THIS GOAL.
WHEN IT COMES TO PREPAREDNESS
FOR PREPARING FOR EMERGENCY AND
MITIGATION?
HAZARDS LOCAL GOVERNMENT PLAYS A
CRITICAL ROLE HERE WITH ME TO
SPEAK IN SUPPORT OF THIS REQUEST.
IS -- RAY RYAN DUNN WAS SAN JOSE
CITY OF SAN JOSE AND ALSO VICE
MAYOR OF SAN JOSE.
CHOPPY JONES.
THANK YOU HONORABLE COMMITTEE
CHAIRED OUT TO OUR MEMBERS OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
SUBCOMMITTEE PANELIST MEMBERS OF
THE PUBLIC HERE TODAY.
I THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MATURE FOR
PRESENTING I REQUEST THAT IS SO
CRITICAL HELP IN THE CITY.
OF SAN JOSE PREPARE FOR THE NEXT
DISASTER.
GOOD AFTERNOON I'M RAMEN RIORDAN
WITH THIRTY TWO YEARS EXPERIENCE
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT.
I JOIN THE CITY OF SAN JOSE
AFTER IT'S DEVASTATING FLOOD IN.
TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN AND HAVE
BEEN DIRECTING THEIR
IMPROVEMENTS IN THE OFFICE OF
THE READY THIS FOR THE NEXT
DISASTER.
DISASTERS ARE LOCAL.
LOCAL POLICE FIRE EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT OF THE FIRST TO
RESPOND.
THE FIRST TO TAKE ACTION THE
FIRST MAKE DECISIONS THAT
ALERTING AND WARNING.
IS A LOCAL GOVERNMENT MUST
MANAGE THE RECOVERY FOLLOWING
THE DISASTER.
WE'RE THE FIRST TUNE THE PUBLIC
LOOKS TO AND EXPECTS INFORMATION
DECISIONS.
A COMMUNITY FOCUSED FOCUSED
LEADERSHIP.
THE GOVERNOR'S OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES ARE CALLOW
YES AND FEMA.
BOTH AGREE AND TEACH THESE
THOUGHTS AND ALL THEIR COURSES.
AS NOTED THE CALIFORNIA --
CALORIE AT ST HAZARD MITIGATION
PLAN.
OUR FUTURE WILL EXPERIENCE WATER
MORE.
OF THE THREE TOP HAZARDS OF
EARTHQUAKE FIRE AND FLOOD.
IT'S NOT A MATTER OF IF.
BUT WHEN WILL IT OCCUR.
THE IMPACT OF THESE HAZARDS ROLE
RIPPER RIPPLE INTO THE STATE'S
ECONOMY.
DEVASTATING BUSINESSES CITIZENS
THE MOST IMPORTANTLY.
THOSE VULNERABLE POPULATIONS
UNABLE TO MANAGE WITHOUT SUPPORT.
INVESTMENT A LOCAL GOVERNMENT
READY MISS AND RESILIENCE WILL
REDUCE THE FUTURE IMPACT SOME
PEOPLE ENVIRONMENT.
AND THE STATE'S ECONOMY.
THE AVAILABLE FUNDS FOR
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS OUR
ADMINISTERED CURRENTLY
ADMINISTERED BY CAROL YES.
DO NOT SUFFICIENTLY SUPPORT
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
RELY ON AN UNSURE FEDERAL BUDGET.
AND REALLY DOES NOT PROVIDE
SUSTAINABILITY.
THE TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
COUNTY CREEK TAUGHT AT SEVERAL
THINGS IN SAN JOSE THAT WE MUST
IMPROVE IN THIS BUT THE FUNDING
WOULD SUPPORT.
IS TO MANAGE THE RESPONSE WITH
AN UPDATED EMERGENCY OPERATIONS
CENTER.
RESIDENTS ARE GREAT CITY ALREADY
AGREED PASSED MEASURE T. FOR THE
BUILDING OF A NEW STRUCTURE.
BUT THE BOND MONEY CANNOT BE
USED FOR THE EQUIPMENT OR
SUPPLIES SO WE WILL HAVE AN EEOC.
THE NOT WOULD NOT YET BE
FUNCTIONAL OKAY I THINK WE HAVE
MOST OF THAT SOMEWHERE IN OUR
AND OUR REPORT SO COULD YOU JUST
GIVE US A SUMMING UP.
OKAY THE SUMMARY THEN IS THAT WE
WILL USE THESE FUNDS TO IMPROVE
MEDICATION ALONG THE STREAM BEDS.
THE REDUCE OUR FLOOD THREATS
IMPROVE OUR CREDENTIALING
CAPABILITY SO OUR STAFF ARE
READY TO RESPOND ALONG WITH THE
PUBLIC.
BECAUSE WE WANT THE PUBLIC
TRAINED TO THANK YOU.
BOB ANY ONE ELSE IN OF THE
MEMBERS HAVE ANY QUESTIONS.
OKAY.
ANYONE ELSE IN THE AUDIENCE.
THE SUPPORTER [inaudible]
OKAY.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU THANK YOU THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR THAT.
WE HAVE A QUORUM NOW I'M GOING
TO ASK SAID WE GIVE A CALL.
OF TAKE THE A ROLL.
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
I'M HERE TO OKAY.
SOMEWHAT.
SOMEWHAT OKAY WE DO HAVE A
QUORUM -- WE HAVE ONE MORE
MEMBER HERE WILL LISTEN TO THIS
MEMBER AND THEN WE'LL GO INTO
OUR AGENDA.
OKAY.
IS THE COOPER.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS
HELLO THANK YOU FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO APPEAR BEFORE YOU.
SPEAK ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF
FUNDING FOR THE INTERNET CRIMES
AGAINST CHILDREN TASK FORCE.
IT COMES CONSTRUED INCEST FORCE
COMMON ONES I CáC IS A NATIONAL
NETWORK OF SIXTY ONE COORDINATED
TASK FORCES.
REPRESENTING OVER THIRTY FIVE
HUNDRED FEDERAL STATE AND LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT PROSECUTION
AGENCIES.
THE AGENCIES ARE CONTINUALLY
ENGAGE IN PROACTIVE AND REACTIVE
INSTIGATION THE PROSECUTION'S OF
PERSONS INVOLVED IN CHILD ABUSE.
AND EXPLOITATION INVOLVING THE
INTERNET.
CALIFORNIA OPERATES FIVE I CáC
TASK FORCES LOCATED FRESNO
SACRAMENTO SAN DIEGO SAN JOSE
AND LOS ANGELES.
THESE LIFESAVING RESOURCES WERE
FIRST ADDED TO THE STATE BUDGET
IN.
TWO THOUSAND EIGHT THE HEIGHT OF
A SEVERE BUDGET CRISIS DESPITE
ELEVEN BILLION SHORTFALL IN
REVENUE THE LEGISLATURE
UNDERSTOOD THE IMPORTANCE OF
PROTECTING CHILDREN.
FROM SEXUAL EXPLOITATION.
WELL TEN MILLION IS A TINY
FRACTION OF THE ENTIRE STATE
BUDGET THE FUNDING IS CRITICAL
TO THE I CAC TASK FORCES.
WHY CáC TASK FORCES ARE THE
ONLY ENTITIES FIND THE FORCING
UNDERGROUND MARKING CHOPPER NOT
YOUR FEE WHICH IS MADE SOCIAL
COMMODITIES OF OUR CHILDREN?
EVERY WEEK CHILDREN ARE RESCUED
DIRECTLY INDIRECTLY BY I CáC
ARREST INVOLVING SEXUAL
PREDATORS.
IS A FORMER COMMANDER OF THE
SECOND ALL I CáC TASK FORCE I A
FOUGHT THE FRONTLINE TO PROTECT
OUR CHILDREN FROM SEXUAL
PREDATORS ONLINE.
NOW'S NOT THE TIME TO GIVE THE
FIGHT.
OUR SURF THE URGE SUPPORT FOR
THIS REQUEST THANK YOU
[inaudible]
SOME.
JEFF.
YOUR OKAY OF ANYONE IN THE
AUDIENCE [inaudible]
OKAY -- WE HAVE SOMEONE OKAY ONE
TO GIVE US YOUR NAME AND YOUR
THREE IS A TAILOR CAROL LOCAL
ATTORNEY AND I AM PERSONALLY
SUPPORTING THE BILL MEMBER OF
ALPHA KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY THANK
YOU.
OKAY.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM ANY MEMBER.
CAN HAVE A GROUP FUNDED THIS
REPORT FOR MILLION PERCENT RIGHT
OKAY.
AND MY STAFF SAYS THAT WE HAVE
SOME DATA AND STATISTICS THAT
HAVE COME BACK FROM THE REPORT
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU --
YEAH I DON'T SEE IT IN OTHER
MEMBER PRESENT AND I'M TRYING TO
DECIDE WHICH WAY.
FOR PUBLIC IN COLLEAGUES TO DO
THE VOTING.
THERE'S NO CURRENT ELSEWHERE.
WHICH YOU YOU YOU WELL.
YEAH WANNA [inaudible]
OKAY.
GIVE A LITTLE BIT MORE TIME LET
THEM KNOW WE'RE LOOKING FOR THEM
TO COME TO DO THE VOTING AGAINST
OUR VOTING AFTER.
YOUR PRESENTATION.
OKAY.
SO YOU THREE INVESTMENT GRANT
MOVE.
GOOD AFTERNOON GOOD MEMBERS I AM
HERE TO REQUEST A HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS TO CONTINUE
FUNDING THE YOU THREE INVESTMENT
GRANT.
WHICH WILL ALLOW COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS PROVIDE OUR MOST
VULNERABLE CHILDREN WITH
CULTURALLY RELEVANT TROM INFORM
SERVICES.
OUTSIDE OF THE JUSTICE SYSTEM
I AM PROUD THAT LAST YEAR I WORK
WITH THIS COMMITTEE LEADERSHIP
AND THE SENATE TO SECURE A
THIRTY SEVEN POINT THREE MILLION.
TO ESTABLISH TO YOU THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT.
I'M HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE THAT SIXTY
CALIFORNIA CITIES.
COUNTIES AND FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES HAVE APPLY
PRETTY YOU THREE INVESTMENT
GRANT.
HOWEVER WE ALL KNOW THAT WAS NOT
ENOUGH FUNDING TO DISMANTLE THE
SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN OF THE
APPROXIMATELY FIFTY SIX THOUSAND
YOUTH ARRESTED NEARLY THIRTY
SEVEN THOUSAND YOUTH 66% WERE
ARRESTED FOR MISDEMEANORS AND
STATUS OFFENSES.
THIS MEANS.
BLOCKING CHILDREN UP FOR ACTIONS
LIKE PETTY THEFT.
SCHOOL FIGHTS SMOKING CANNABIS.
RUNNING AWAY AND VIOLATING
CURFEW.
A LOT OF THINGS A LOT OF US WITH
GRAY HAIR.
USED TO DO BACK IN A DAY I WON'T
NAME ANY NAMES.
HOW DO WE JUSTIFY TO THE
CALIFORNIA TAXPAYERS THAT WE'RE
SPENDING BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED AND
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR TO KEEP A?
CHILD LOCKED UP FOR THINGS LIKE
THAT GIVEN THOSE THIRTY SEVEN
THOUSAND KIDS OUT OF THE SYSTEM
WILL SAVE US OVER.
SEVEN BILLION WITH A B..
DOLLARS PER YEAR.
DO YOU THREE INVESTMENT FUND
PROPOSAL WILL ALLOCATE A HUNDRED
MILLION TO FUND LOCAL YOUTH
DEVELOPMENT AND PRE ARREST
DIVERSION PROGRAMS FOR CHILDREN.
UP TO EIGHTEEN YEARS UNDER THE
JURISDICTION OF THE JUVENILE
JUSTICE SYSTEM IN AND
UNDERSERVED COMMUNITIES.
WITH ME TO TESTIFY.
AN URGENT SUPPORT FOR THIS
IMPORTANT INVESTMENT TODAY.
IS COMMANDER JUROR JUROR WOODARD
OF THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT AND YES THE POLICE DO
SUPPORT -- YOU THREE INVESTMENT
IN HELPING YOUTH OUTSIDE OF THE
CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM --
MEMBERS ARE RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YA VOTE.
I'LL BE EXTREMELY BRIEF -- I WAS
HERE LAST YEAR AND REALLY
EXCITED ABOUT THIRTY SEVEN POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLARS THAT WE
WERE ABLE TO SECURE.
THE LOS ANGELES DEPARTMENT IS IN
FULL SUPPORT OF WORKING WITH OUR
COMMUNITY BASED ORGANIZATIONS AS
OPPOSED AN ARREST IN A A KID WE
KNOW THAT THAT WILL HAVE AN
IMPACT A LONG LASTING IMPACT ON
THE KID.
WE WOULD PREFER THAT THOSE
COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS TAKE
THAT KID IN A WRAP THE BILL
SERVICES AROUND THEM TO GET TO
THE ROOT CAUSES OF OF THAT --
AVERETT BRAVE YEAR.
NOW WE'RE TALKING ABOUT LOW
LEVEL OFFENSES.
AND SO WE ARE IN FULL SUPPORT.
OF OF OF GETTING MORE FUNDING --
WE HAVE TWENTY ONE DIVISIONS IN
THE LOS ANGELES POLICE
DEPARTMENT.
AND WE'RE ONLY ABLE TO SUPPORT
SIXTEEN AND WE'RE PART OF THAT
THAT COUNTY COLLABORATIVE OF
SIXTY ON LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES SOUL WE ARE A FULL
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
ANY COMMENTS FROM MEMBERS.
OKAY I ASSUME ALL THOSE FOLKS
WHO CAME IN WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING.
OF I HAVE TO DECIDE IF WE GO LET
THAT HAPPEN -- IT'S ONLY BE A
FIVE MINUTE COURTESY
PRESENTATION BY THE MEMBER.
SO IF YOU IF YOU REPRESENT A
SPECIFIC ORGANIZATION IF THERE'S
SEVERAL BE WITH THE SAME
ORGANIZATION.
THEN WHEN YOUR ORGANIZATION GETS
UP INSTEAD OF EVERYBODY WANTING
TO TALK IT'S JUST HAVE THOSE
MEMBERS IN THE AUDIENCE STAND.
FRIENDS AS I SEE IT THE A.
KAYSER HERE AND THEY WANT TO SAY
SOMETHING THAT'S HAVE AN A. K.
A. SPREE AND THE REST OF YOU CAN
BE THE STAND AROUND THEM OR
STAND IN THE AUDIENCE.
THAT WE WILL GET THE FULL EFFECT
OF IT BUT WE DON'T NEED TO HAVE
EVERYONE TELL US THE SAME
ORGANIZATION OVER OVER.
AND GIVES ORGANIZATION AND THAT
YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY THESE OF FOLKS
IN FAVOR OF THE BILL SO TELL US
YOUR NAME AND YOUR ORGANIZATION.
AND WILL KNOW THAT YOU REPRESENT
YOUR SUPPORT IT YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MICHAEL
HARRIS NATIONAL CENTER FOR YOUTH
LAW STRONGLY IN SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON A GIOVANNI DOOR
SELL WITH YOUTH MENTOR
CONNECTION IN LOS ANGELES AND
WE'RE HAPPY TO SUPPORT THIS LOS
ANGELES TO SAVE LIVES THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
HELLO HI I'M JULIA BUT AS MUCH
AGO FROM THE FRONT AND THEN YOU
JUST HAVE YOUR BAND OF MISSION
INDIANS.
AND WHEN SUPPORT.
HUH. TWO OF YOU GOOD.
WONDER WILLIAMS INDIVIDUAL IN
SUPPORT MOTHER SAID OF THE
FATHERS IN FAMILIES AND ALPHA
KAPPA ALPHA SORORITY
INCORPORATED THANK YOU.
CABLE INDIAN ALLIANCE FOR BOYS
AND MEN OF COLOR AND POLICY LINK
THANK YOU.
IRVING OFFERS YOUTH JUSTICE
COALITION I HAVE BEEN IMPACTED
FROM SCHOOL TO PRISON PIPELINE.
I BELIEVE THAT ALL THE ISRAEL
FOR JUST WANTED WHO YOU ARE WHAT
WOULD YOU REPRESENT WE KNOW
YOU'RE IN FAVOR OF IT.
OKAY THANK YOU OKAY THANK YOU.
JASIM DELPHOS THE GATHERING FOR
JUST THE STOCKTON CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU.
TWILA MUSLIM AMERICAN INDIAN
MOVEMENT PROGRAMS.
THANK YOU.
THE ONLY A SHARP CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL FAMILIES COALITION IN
STRONG SUPPORT THANK YOU OKAY
THANK YOU VERY MUCH WELL THANK
ALL OF YOU FOR COMING THIS IS A
NUMBER WE DON'T HEAR THESE IN
COMMITTEE SO AS A CONSPIRACY. TO
TO OUR MEMBERS I DECIDED THAT I
WOULD HEAR THESE SUBCOMMITTEE
REQUEST NORMALLY THEY JUST
REQUEST A COME IN WE DECIDE WHAT
WE'RE GOING TO WHAT I'M BUT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WILL MOVE THAT -- THANK YOU
MISTER JONES SAWYER GONNA MOVE
BACK INTO THE AGENDA.
AND SINCE WE HAVE A MORE THAN A
QUORUM.
I'M SORRY OKAY -- WE'RE GONNA GO
THROUGH ITEMS WE HAVE FOURTEEN
ITEMS THAT ARE BOTH ONLY ITEM SO
I WANT TO RESPECT THE TIME OF
THE MEMBERS BECAUSE THEY KNOW
SOME OF THEM WERE IN OTHER
MEETINGS.
AND THEN WE CAN GO BACK IN HERE
MEMBER PRESENTATIONS AS WELL AS
ITEMS THAT ARE GOING TO BE
PRESENTED TO DATE BUT ARE NOT
GOING TO BE VOTED ON THEIR
FOURTEEN ITEMS TO VOTE ON WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN WITH ITEM NUMBER.
ONE ISSUE ONE WHICH IS A
CALIFORNIA INTER OPERABLE PUBLIC
SAFETY RADIO SYSTEM.
IT IS IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECOND
OF ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES
SAWYER [inaudible]
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT IS OUT ON A FOR ALL
WILL HOLD THE RAP FOR THE ROLE
OPEN FOR THE OTHER MEMBER --
ISSUE NUMBER TWO WHICH IS
CAPITAL OUTLAY RED MOUNTAIN
COMMUNICATION SIDE PROJECT.
IT'S BEEN MOVED SECOND SECOND
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE YEAH
THAT'S FOR ALSO -- WILL HOLD THE
RECORD THE ROLE OPEN.
ISSUE NUMBER THREE WHICH IS A
SPRING LETTER HER OWN
REAPPROPRIATION.
MOST SECOND OKAY WELL HELLO
WHATEVER I JONES SAWYER HI
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT'S FOR ONCE AGAIN.
OUT OF THE FOUR OH WILL HOLD OF
WILL OPEN ISSUE NUMBER FOUR
WHICH IS A CANNABIS CONVICTIONS
RE SENTENCING I MOVE THE BILL.
IT'S BEEN MOVED AND SECONDED
ROLL CALL WEBER I'M JONES SAWYER
DEFINITELY I LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE OKAY THAT ALL
AVERAGES OUT TO AN OUTSIDE OKAY
THAT'S FOR IT WILL HOLD IT OPEN
ALSO.
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE WHICH
MEDICATION DISTRIBUTION
IMPROVEMENTS PHASE.
TWO IT'S BEEN MODES SECOND
SECOND.
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY NOT VOTING MELENDEZ STONE.
HEY THAT'S THREE OH AND ONE OF
ONE NOT VOTING AT THE OUTLETS
OUT ALSO WILL HOLD A ROLL OPEN --
ISSUE NUMBER SIX STATEWIDE
BUDGET PIC PACKAGES AND ADVANCE
PLANNING.
THE MOTION.
SECOND MOVEMENT SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT'S OUT ON FOR WILL HOLD
IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER SEVEN WHICH
IS PELICAN BAY CLASSROOM SPACE
REAPPROPRIATION.
THEIR MOTION SECOND.
WHATEVER TO THE MOTION THE LOVE
ALL THE WORLD I'M SORRY MOVE
THIS SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER.
JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE GATE.
THAT'S A THREE OH WOULD ONE NOT
KNOW AT THIS -- THREE TO ONE
THAT IS OUT AND WILL HOLD IT
OPEN.
OKAY ITEM NUMBER EIGHT WHICH IS
PELICAN BAY FIRE SUPPRESSION
UPGRADE.
THE ROOM IS SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER HI LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S A FOUR OH VOTE IN WILL HOLD
IT OPEN.
I ISSUE NUMBER NINE PUBLIC IN
BAY DE YARD WE APPROPRIATIONS.
SO WHEN MODE I CAN'T SECOND ROLL
CALL.
WEBER HI JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE THAT'S THREE TO
ONE THATIS OUT BUT WE'LL KEEP
THE ROLE OPEN.
OF ISSUE NUMBER TEN WHICH IS
ROOF THE ROOF REPLACEMENT DESIGN
AND CONSTRUCTION.
SO WHEN WILL SECOND SECOND OKAY
ROLL CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IF IT IS OUT ON A FOR VOTE --
AND WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN A
CALIFORNIA CORRECTIONAL HEALTH
CARE SERVICES LEASING AGREEMENT.
ORGANIZATION.
MOVED IN SECOND ROLL CALL WEBER
I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
THAT'S A FOR VOTERS OUT WILL
HOLD IT OPEN ISSUE NUMBER TWELVE
WHICH IS THE CDC ADMINISTRATIVE
CHANGE TRAILER BILL SO MOM.
SECOND WELCOME WEBER I'M JONES
SAWYER.
LACKEY.
MELENDEZ STONE.
IT'S OUT ON A FOR ALL WILL HOLD
IT OVER -- ISSUE NUMBER THIRTEEN
WAS REAPPROPRIATION OF AB NINE
HUNDRED GENERAL FUND.
WHEN I OPENED SECOND ROLL CALL
WEBER I JONES SAWYER?
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE.
OKAY THAT'S A FOUR OH VOTE WILL
HOLD IT OPEN WAITING. FOR THE
OTHER MEMBERS THAT THAT'S OUT IN
ISSUE FOURTEEN AUGMENTATION OF
INMATE WELFARE FUND OF FORTY
SECOND SAID MOVED IN SECOND ROLL
CALL WEBER I JONES SAWYER.
LACKEY MELENDEZ STONE OKAY ALL
THOSE THAT'S OUT ON A FOR VOTE
WILL HOLD THE ROLE OPEN FOR THE
ABSENT MEMBERS.
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO VOTE I
THINK WE HAD A MEMBER WHO CAME
IN WAS TO GABRIEL -- YOUR AND
YOUR PRESENTATION NOW YOU HAVE
FIVE MINUTES TOTAL.
OKAY
[inaudible]
YES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM CHAIR
AND MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TODAY
TO PRESENT MY BUDGET REQUEST
WHICH WILL ALLOCATE TWENTY
MILLION DOLLARS TO THE JUDICIAL
BRANCH. FOR EXPANSION IN
ADMINISTRATION OF THE HIGHLY
SUCCESSFUL SERGEANT SHRIVER'S
CIVIL COUNCIL ACT PROGRAMS.
THESE PROGRAMS ARE ADMINISTERED
BY THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL AND
OPERATED BY LEGAL SERVICES
NONPROFITS WORKING IN
COLLABORATIONS WITH LOCAL COURTS.
THE SEARCH SHRIVER PROGRAM
PROVIDES LEAK VITAL LEGAL
REPRESENTATION TO LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIANS IN LIFE CHANGING
CIVIL LEGAL MATTERS.
IN MANY CASES HAVING AN ATTORNEY
CAN BE THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
HAVING A HOME ARE BEING AFFECTED
GAINING OR LOSING CUSTODY OF A
CHILD OR SECURING A GARDEN.
YOUR GUARDIAN OR CONSERVATORSHIP
FOR LOVE.
ONE IN TWO THOUSAND SEVENTEEN
THE JUDICIAL COUNCIL RELEASED AN
EVALUATION WHICH FOUND THAT
THESE PROGRAMS NOT ONLY
DRAMATICALLY IMPROVED OUTCOMES
FOR LITIGANTS.
BUT ALSO THAT THEY INCREASE
SETTLEMENTS REDUCE COSTS ON THE
COURT SYSTEM AND PROVIDED
NUMEROUS OTHER EFFICIENCIES.
IN SHORT THE EVALUATION
DEMONSTRATED THAT THE SHRIVER
PROGRAM HELPS LOW INCOME
CALIFORNIA SECURE ACCESS TO
JUSTICE.
IT CLEARLY DEMONSTRATES THE
URGENT NEED TO SCALE TRIVERS
PROGRAMS AND SERVICES.
FUNDING HAS BEEN AND REMAINS AN
ISSUE FOR THESE PROGRAMS.
FUNDED BY CERTAIN CIVIL FILING
FEES THE SHRIVER PROGRAMS HAVE
RECEIVED LESS MONEY EACH YEAR AS
CIVIL FILINGS HAVE DECREASED.
ORIGINALLY PROJECTED TO HAVE
ELEVEN MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY
THE SHRIVER PROGRAMS ONLY
RECEIVED ABOUT FOUR FIVE POINT
FOUR MILLION IN THE 200-017-2000
EIGHTEEN FISCAL YEAR.
INSTEAD OF EXPANDING THEIR
SERVICES SHRIVER ACT PROGRAMS OF
HAD TO SCALE BACK THE NUMBER OF
CASES THEY CAN ACCEPT AND FOREGO
CREATING NEW PROGRAMS IN OTHER
AREAS OF THE STATE.
INVESTING IN THIS WHERE THE
PROGRAM ALLOW MORE CALIFORNIANS
IN MORE PARTS OF THE STATE TO
ACCESS JUSTICE.
THE INFLUX OF THIS MONEY WILL
HELP SERVE MORE LOW INCOME
LITIGANTS ALLOW PROGRAMS TO HELP
OTHER UNDERSERVED POPULATIONS.
EXPAND SERVICES TO OTHER
CRITICAL AREAS SUCH AS DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AND ESTABLISH NEW
PROGRAMS IN OTHER PARTS OF THE
STATE.%
I JUST WANNA SAY THE THE
FUNDAMENTAL THESIS BEHIND THIS
BILL IS THAT JUSTICE SHOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO EVERYBODY IN THE
STATE.
REGARDLESS OF YOUR INCOME AND
REGARDLESS OF YOUR ABILITY TO
AFFORD AN ATTORNEY AND WE SEE IN
SO MANY AREAS THE LAW THAT
HAVING AN ATTORNEY OR NOT HAVING
ATTORNEY IS REALLY OUTCOME
DETERMINATIVE AND SO FOR THE THE
THE CALIFORNIANS OF THE LEAST
MEANS THIS PROGRAM PROVIDES THEM.
WITH ATTORNEYS AND WE'VE SEEN
THAT THAT'S MADE A HUGE
DIFFERENCE IN THEIR CASES AND
IT'S ACTUALLY BEEN A BENEFIT TO
THE JUDICIAL SYSTEM AND HAS SAVE
THE STATE MONEY.
AND I APPRECIATE YOUR TIME AND
CONSIDERATION OF THIS REQUEST
WOULD BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THE COMMITTEE WHERE HE
MAY HAVE.
AND WITH ME TO TESTIFY IS GERRY
SMITH THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
LEGAL SERVICES OF NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA.
GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS MADAM
CHAIR.
THANKS FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO BE
HERE I'M THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR
LEGAL SERVICE NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA WE PROVIDE FREE CIVIL
LEGAL SERVICES IN TWENTY THREE
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA COUNTIES AND
WE ARE ONE OF THE TEN SHRIVER
CIVIL COUNCIL.
PROJECTS WHICH WE OPERATE.
UNDER THE UNDER THE PARTNERSHIP
OF DEAL COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT IN
OUR OFFICE IN -- WOODLAND.
BY I THINK THAT -- IT BEARS
EMPHASISED THAT THIS HAS BEEN
ALWAYS A BI PARTISAN PROJECT.
GOVERNOR SCHWARTZ AND I
SCHWARZENEGGER SIGNED A. B. FIVE
NINETY IN TWO THOUSAND AND NINE
AND NAMED AFTER HIS FATHER IN
LAW [inaudible] TO REMOTE THE
THE THE IDEA OF ACCESS TO
JUSTICE IN THE COURTS OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE PROJECT HAS RECEIVED
NATIONAL ATTENTION AND
RECOGNITION AS A POLICY
INITIATIVE TOWARDS A VISION OF
COMPREHENSIVE ACCESS TO JUSTICE.
OUR PROGRAM IN PARTNERSHIP WITH
THE LA COUNTY SUPERIOR COURT IS
BEEN OPERATING THIS PROJECT
SINCE TWENTY TWELVE AND HAS
ASSISTED OVER TWO THOUSAND
TENANTS.
SINCE THAT TIME OUR CLIENTS
INCLUDE PEOPLE WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY SURVIVORS OF
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE OLDER ADULTS
VETERANS AND PEOPLE WITH
SIGNIFICANT DISABILITIES IN
HERE'S HOW THE YOLO COUNTY
PRESIDING JUDGE.
RECENTLY DESCRIBED THIS PROJECT
QUOTE IT IMPROVES ACCESS TO
JUSTICE FOR UNLAWFUL DETAINER
LITIGANTS BY REDUCING THE
DISPARITY THAT EXISTS IN
REPRESENTATION IN A FICTION
CASES.
IT PROVIDES LANGUAGE ACCESS FOR
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENT
LITIGANTS IT ENCOURAGES
SETTLEMENT THROUGH MEDIATION AND
OFFERS NEUTRAL EXPERT WITNESS
TESTIMONY IN CASES INVOLVING
SUBSTANDARD.
HOUSING AND IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GABRIEL HAS POINTED OUT THIS
PROGRAM HAS BEEN SCRUPULOUSLY
ADMINISTERED BY THE JUDICIAL
COUNCIL AND RIGOROUSLY EVALUATED
BY AN INDEPENDENT OF VALUE.
EVALUATOR WITH -- IMPERIAL IT
EMPIRICALLY DOCUMENTED POSITIVE
RESULTS AND I WOULD URGE YOUR
SUPPORT THANK YOU ANY COMMENTS
OR QUESTIONS -- WE HAVE SOMEONE
WANTS TO JUST GIVE THE NAME AND
SAY THEY SUPPORT YES.
MADAM TURN MEMBER SYLVIA SOLELY
SHAUN BEHALF OF LOS ANGELES CITY
ATTORNEY MIKE FEWER AUTHOR OF
THE IMPLEMENTING LEGISLATION
PROGRAM HAS A SUCCESSFUL TRACK
RECORD AND WE ARE IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF THIS BUDGET REQUEST
THANK YOU.
WHAT IS THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN
THIS AND THE LEGAL AID SOCIETY
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT THE
DIFFERENCE OF THE DIFFERENT
JURISDICTION -- EQUAL ACCESS.
THE EQUAL ACCESS -- ONE MADAM
CHAIR -- GENERALLY FUNDS CIVIL
LEGAL SERVICES FOR POOR PEOPLE
AND AND THERE ARE OVER ONE
HUNDRED ORGANIZATIONS THEY GET
THAT.
MONEY THAT FUNDING THE SHRIVER
PROJECT IS A VERY SPECIFIC
PROGRAM AND THERE ARE TEN OF
THEM NOW IN THE STATE.
ALL OF THE ORGANIZATIONS THAT
RECEIVE SHRIVER PROJECT ARE ALSO
RECIPIENTS OF THE EQUAL ACCESS
FUNDING BUT THIS IS SPECIFIC
DESIGNATED FUNDS TO DO
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE COURTS. TO
TRY AND LEVEL THE PLAYING FIELD
IN CERTAIN SUBJECT AREAS LIKE
HOUSING CUSTODY IN AND OTHER
FAMILY WOMEN IN THE WAY THAT WAS
DESCRIBED IN THE ORIGINAL
LEGISLATION IS A LIFE CHANGING
CIVIL LEGAL MATTERS SO THESE ARE
CASES WHERE THERE IS THE MOST ON
THE LINE FOR FOLKS THEY'RE
FACING.
THE POSSIBILITY OF INFECTION
THERE FACING THE POSSIBILITY OF
LOSING CUSTODY OF A CHILD THE
TYPE OF THINGS AND HAVE A
DRAMATIC IMPACT ON ONE'S LIFE.
AND IT'S FOCUSED ON FOLKS OR
2100% BELOW THE POVERTY LETTER
SO IT'S THE MOST LOW INCOME
FOLKS IN THE HIGH STAKES CASES
OKAY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
VERY MUCH.
I THINK WE HAVE MISTER RAMOS
HERE
.
WE CATION -- HE DID ON THE OTHER
ONE HE WAY THAT PRESENTATION YES.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR AND A
MEMBERS I'M HERE TODAY TO
PRESENT A REQUEST FOR TEN
MILLION DOLLARS. TO INCREASE THE
FUNDING FOR TROUBLE YOU TO
VERSION GRANT PROGRAM.
UNDER THE U. THREE INVESTMENT
GRANT.
TODAY'S A NATIVE AMERICAN YOUTH
HAVE INHERITED A LEGACY OF
HISTORICAL TRAUMA.
CAUSED BY LOSS OF HOME LAND
CULTURE.
VISIBILITY AND LANGUAGE AS A
RESULT OF CENTURIES OF A RADIC
CATION AND ASSIMILATION BASED
POLICIES.
CALIFORNIA HAS THE HIGHEST
POPULATION OF NATIVE AMERICANS
IN THE NATION.
AND A MAJORITY LIVE OFF
RESERVATION.
THE ISSUES OF PROPERTY LACK OF
RESOURCES AND DISPOSITION OUR
ISSUES ON AND OFF RESERVATIONS
IN URBAN AND RURAL AREAS.
TODAY'S NATIVE AMERICAN YOU HAVE
INHERITED A LEGACY OF HISTORICAL
TRAUMA.
CAUSED BY THE LOSS OF A HOME.
TRIBES IN OUR STATE WANT TO
EXPAND PROGRAMS INFORMED BY THE
WEIGHT OF HISTORY AND THEIR
CURRENT LIVES EXPERIENCE WILL
STRENGTHEN THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES.
IT WILL BE AN IMPORTANT STEP IN
IMPROVING OUTCOMES FOR ALL
NATIVE AMERICAN YOU.
I WANT TO HIGHLIGHT THAT WELL
THIS REQUEST FOCUSES ON THE
RECOGNIZED TRIBES IN OUR STATE.
WE HAVE TO START.
TO LOOK AT THE MISCONCEPTIONS
THAT ARE OUT THERE.
MISCONCEPTIONS THAT TODAY.
EVERY TRAVEL GOVERNMENT IS BEING
SUCCESSFUL WITH ECONOMIC SUCCESS
TO GAMING OR OTHER AREAS THAT'S
JUST NOT THE CASE.
THE MAJORITYOF THE CALIFORNIA
PEOPLE STILL LIVE BELOW THE
POVERTY LEVEL STATUS
INFRASTRUCTURAL NEEDS ARE STILL
THEIR SOCIAL NEEDS ARE STILL
THERE.
SO WE NEED TO START TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND MOVE
FORWARD IN REQUESTING THESE
TYPES OF GRANTS IN FRONT OF US
TODAY.
AND WILL CONTINUE TO ADVOCATE ON
THESE NEEDS.
THIS BUDGET REQUEST PROVIDES
FOCUSES ON PROVIDING TRIBES THE
RESOURCES TO CONNECT WITH YOU.
TO PROVIDE THEM THE RESOURCES
THEY NEED AND TO DIVERT AWAY
FROM THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BACK BY BACK TOWARDS THEIR
COMMUNITIES TRIBAL COMMUNITIES
IN OUR STATE HAVE BEEN ON THE
FRONT LINES.
WORKING TIRELESSLY TO IMPROVE
OUTCOMES FOR YOU.
BUT HAVEN'T RECEIVED THE SUPPORT
THEY DESERVE.
THIS IN FRONT OF US NOW IS A TEN
MILLION ASK LAST.
SESSION THERE WAS A MILLION
DOLLARS IT MOVED INTO IT WE NEED
MORE IN INDIAN COUNTRY TO BE
ABLE TO START TO SEE THE IMPACTS.
THAT WE CAN SEE AND MOVING
FORWARD IN THE TRIBAL
COMMUNITIES.
THE FUNDING TRIES A FEW RECEIVED
FOR YOUTH DEVELOPMENT DIVERSION
PROGRAMS MUST BE ADEQUATE TO
EXPAND PROGRAMS AND IMPROVE
OUTCOMES.
AND STABLE TO ENSURE THAT
EFFECTIVE PROGRAMS ARE NOT LOST
IN A YEAR TO YEAR CYCLE.
WHICH IS WHY I AM PROUD TO
SUPPORT THIS REQUEST.
WITH ME TODAY I HAVE DIVINE.
LEE LOW MAYES SEPA.
CHIEF JUDGE AND THE INTER TRIBAL
COURT OF SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS DALY
A SHARP FROM THE CALIFORNIA
TRAVEL FAMILIES COALITION.
AND THE FINA GO XENA FROM THE
CALIFORNIA YOUTH JUSTICE
INITIATIVE OKAY WILL HAVE A
MINUTE FROM EACH ONE OF YOU.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON
CHAIRMAN WEBER AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE AND THANK YOU
ASSEMBLYMAN RAMOS FOR YOUR
LEADERSHIP AND COMMITMENT TO
THIS VERY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
MY NAME IS TO FOLLOW MY SAID I'M
A MEMBER OF THE PAIN NATION OF
SANTA ISABEL LOCATED IN SAN
DIEGO COUNTY -- I AM AN ATTORNEY
PRACTICING TRIBAL AND FEDERAL
INDIAN LAW AND I'M ALSO AS
STATED THE CHIEF JUDGE OF THE
INTER TRIBAL COURT OF SEVEN
CALIFORNIA SERVING OVER A DOZEN
TRIBES IN THE STATE.
AS STATED CALIFORNIA'S HOME TO
ONE HUNDRED NINE FEDERALLY
RECOGNIZED TRIBES SECOND ONLY TO
THE STATE OF ALASKA.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO THE
LARGEST POPULATION OF NATIVE
AMERICAN PEOPLE IN THE NATION
AND THE LARGEST URBAN INDIAN
POPULATIONS LOCATED PRIMARILY IN
LOS ANGELES.
AND SAN FRANCISCO COUNTIES.
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
DRASTICALLY UNDER FUNDS
CALIFORNIA TRIBES BECAUSE
CALIFORNIA RETAINS CAL CRIMINAL
JURISDICTION.
OVER TRIBAL YOUTH MAKING TRIBAL
YOUTH THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE SYSTEM.
HOWEVER WHAT WE DO KNOW FROM
EXPERIENCE AND THE AVAILABLE
DATA.
IS THAT THE STATE PROGRAMMING
THAT IS AVAILABLE DOES NOT MEET
THE NEEDS OF OUR TRAVEL YOU.
INSTEAD CULTURALLY SPECIFIC
SERVICES PROVIDED BY TRIBES ARE
TRIBAL ORGANIZATIONS ARE
NECESSARY TO ADDRESS THE UNIQUE
NEEDS OF OUR CHILDREN COULD YOU
SUM IT UP YES MA'AM THANK YOU.
BASED ON THAT.
CALIFORNIA TRIBES HAVE ALREADY
BEGUN TO PUT THESE PROGRAMS INTO
PLACE BUT NEED ADDITIONAL
SUPPORT TO BE SUCCESSFUL. TO
REDUCE.
THE DISPERSION IT RATES HAVE
DROPPED OUT ALCOHOL AND DRUG
ABUSE AND SUICIDE.
AND WITH THAT -- WE HOPE THAT
THIS FUNDING WILL OFFER AN
ADDITIONAL OPPORTUNITY FOR ARE
USED TO LIVE UP TO THEIR FULL
POTENTIAL AND MAINTAIN OUR
TRIBAL COMMUNITIES WITH STRONG
AND EDUCATED PULL.
A FUTURE LEADERSHIP THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER PERSON HAVE A MINUTE
PRESENTATION JUST YOUR ADDRESS
ANY QUESTIONS OKAY ALL RIGHT
THEN AND SO YOU'RE YOU'RE
PROPOSAL REQUEST IMITATION IS.
TO WE WOULD THEN THE MEDIA YOU
THREE INVESTMENT GRANT IS THAT
WHAT IT IS I BECAUSE I WAS
REFERENCE.
MADE TO IT -- TO THE VIEW THREE
INVESTMENT GRANT AND THE YOUTH
WE INVEST IN GRANTS FOR A
HUNDRED MILLION SO THIS IS A
PART OF THAT PROPOSAL IS THAT
CORRECT [inaudible]
NO.
LAST YEAR IT WAS THE ONE MILLION
DOLLAR AND WAS INVESTED THIS
YEAR WE'RE DOING AS A SEPARATE
ASKING THAT THE SEPARATE TEN
MILLION DOLLAR ASK OUTSIDE OF
THE U..
SO IT'S OKAY SO IT IS NOT WITHIN
THE THREE INVESTMENT NOTE A DISS.
AS YOU KNOW -- MISTER RAMOS.
IS THE FIRST NATIVE AMERICAN.
ELECTED TO THE ASSEMBLY.
SO HE CAN ASK. FOR ITS OWN SELF
TO GET OKAY.
FOR WELL I I WAS RUNNING BECAUSE
IT IT IF THERE WAS A REFERENCE
TO THE REINVESTMENT YOUTH
PROGRAMS OUT BECAUSE IT WAS KIND
OF PARTNERS PART OF THE THIRTY
SEVEN POINT THREE B. YEAH LAST
TIME YEAH OKAY NO PROBLEM OKAY.
NO PROBLEM ANYONE ELSE IN THE
AUDIENCE WHO JUST WANT TO ME.
TO HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE OKAY.
NOW AS WE DO WITH THE LAST GROUP
IF YOU REPRESENT THE SAME
ORGANIZATION ONE OF YOU SPREE
JUST LET US KNOW YOU ARE AND THE
REST OF YOU CAN WAVE YOUR HAND
SAY YOU WITH THEM.
OKAY.
CREATE GOMEZ QUIT SOUND TRIBE OF
THE YOUNG WOMAN'S FREEDOM CENTER.
CLIPPERS THE CZECHO AND THIS
NUMBER IS A JINGLE FOR THEM FROM
THE FRONT AND THEN YOU TO
TOPPING BAND OF MISSION INDIANS
AND WE SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
HI MY NAME IS THE GOVERNMENT A
THALYS FOR WITH ME IS THE WHITE
Là MAZDA AND TO MELAMINE AS
WELL AND I'M FROM THE PAY NATION
OF SAN ISABELLE REPRESENTING ERR
PRO.
AMERICAN INDIAN RECRUITMENT I
WAS SUPPORT THIS SINCERELY THANK
YOU.
KAELIN DEAN ALIGNS FOR BOYS AND
MEN OF COLOR AT POLICY LINK.
THANK YOU.
GIOVANNI YOURSELF FROM LOS
ANGELES AND YOUTH MENTOR
CONNECTION IN SUPPORT OF YOUTH
REINVESTMENT.
THANK YOU.
THE GATHERING FOR DOES THE
SOUTHERN ELEVADA SYMBOLISM
FAMILIES THE SAN JOAQUIN.
DJOSER GONZALEZ -- LA YOU JUST
COALITION FOR SUPPORT.
WE'RE ALSO QUITE ALL RIGHT
SOUNDS GOOD THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT NHà ANY OTHER
QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU FOR THE PRESENTATION.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
CAN I TAKE THIS BACK TO OUR
AGENDA.
OF THE TOP OF OUR AGENDA SOARED
NOW AT WHERE WE AT ISSUE ITEM
NUMBER.
I GO -- ISSUE ONE WHICH IS THE
BROADBAND COMMUNICATIONS AND
NINE ONE ONE INTEGRATION
.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU [inaudible]
GERMAN -- THIS IS -- MONIES MUCH
BETTER GET A CHEN WITH THEIR
GOVERNOR'S OPTOMETRIC EMERGENCY
SERVICES AND WITH ME TODAY IS.
MUCH CURRIER WHO'S OUR BRANCH
MANAGER FOR NINE ONE ONE AT THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE MUCH SERVICES.
WE'RE HERE TODAY OBVIOUSLY -- TO
A SEEKER ASSISTANCE -- WITH THE
BOOK SERIES OF ITEMS THAT AFFECT
OUR OUR SET AN ACCOUNT OUR FIRST
IS A ONE MILLION DOLLAR -- AND
SIX POSITIONS TO SUPPORT OUR
BROADBAND INITIATIVE THAT'S THE
BROADBAND -- INTEGRATION BETWEEN
FIRST MET AND OUR NEXT GEN NINE
ONE ONE SO THAT'S WHERE WE'RE
MOVING THERE.
ADDITIONALLY THE FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR -- GENERAL FUND A TO
ADDRESS OUR SHORTFALL THAT WE
FORESEE COMING FORWARD WITH THIS.
AND THEN LASTLY THE MODIFICATION
OF THE TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE.
HOW TO MODERNIZE THAT OF THE
STRUCTURE?
OF FOR CALIFORNIA.
I THINK -- WE HAD YOUR SUPPORT
LAST YEAR AND WE'RE LOOKING
FORWARD TO THAT AGAIN -- THIS
YEAR A FROM THE ASSEMBLY -- WE
ARE EVERYTHING THAT WE WANT TO
DO WITH A NINE ONE ONE IS
CONTINGENT ON THE TRAILER BILL --
PASSING AND HAVING SUFFICIENT
REVENUE -- SO WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD WITH -- ALL OF THE
PROPOSALS QUESTION I WON ONE
IT'S AN AGING STRUCTURED SYSTEM.
IT IS NOT GOING -- TO ALLOW US --
TO TO PROPERLY.
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA'S TODAY AND
SO.
WE DON'T DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT --
PEOPLE'S LIVES ARE AT STAKE AND
THAT'S THAT'S REALLY THE
FUNDAMENTAL PIECE FOR US -- WITH
OUR NINE ONE ONE JUST FOR
FAMILIARITY FOR THE COMMITTEE
WE'RE GONNA RESTRUCTURE FROM --
BASICALLY A POINT FIVE TO THREE
QUARTERS OF 1% INTO A FLAT FEE
OF FORCE THAT'LL BE SET FROM A
RANGE FROM ZERO TO EIGHTY A
SENSE.
I WILL DO THAT I ANNUALLY --
WITH YOUR OVERSIGHT ON THE
APPROPRIATION AMOUNT THAT WE CAN
SET THAT FEE STRUCTURE FOR US.
REALLY AT THIS POINT A SUB FOR
QUESTIONS I CAN BE HAPPY TO
ANSWER ANY OF FOLLOWING
QUESTIONS REGARDING BROADBAND OR
OF THE ADDITIONAL ITEMS WITHIN
ON THE SET NOW A TRAILER BILL.
OR ANY OTHER LANGUAGE THAT YOU
HAVE A REGARDING THE FIFTY
MILLION DOLLAR AUGMENTATION
[inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
COMING TO LA L. HUNGER THROUGH
THE LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
WE'RE NOT RAISING SPECIFIC
CONCERNS WITH EITHER THAT --
BUDGET REQUEST OR WITH THE
LANGUAGE -- WITH NO OF COURSE
THAT THIS FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS
IS PROVIDED FROM THE GENERAL
FUND CLEARLY THERE'S A TRADE OFF
BETWEEN USING GENERAL FUND TO
SUPPORT THESE ACTIVITIES WERE
SAYS RAISING FEES -- DEPENDS ON
YOUR LEGISLATIVE PRIORITIES.
RIGHT OKAY FINE THANK ANY
QUESTIONS.
OKAY -- ANY COMMENTS FROM THE
AUDIENCE -- WOULD JUST ME TO USE.
FIFTEEN KERN COUNTY SHERIFF OF
BI<c.cyan> COUNTY -- ALSO THE</c>
CONFERENCE THIS YEAR CESSATION.
A MEMBER OF THE STATE NINE ONE
ONE ADVISORY BOARD AND I'M IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JEFF MASSON
REPRESENT CALIFORNIA FIRE CHIEFS
ASSOCIATION WE SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JOHN FAMILY
REPRESENTING CALIFORNIA
COALITION AGAINST SEXUAL ASSAULT
WE SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON JESSICA SEVEN TEN
THE ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSOCIATION OF COUNTIES
AND SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON A MARKET -- FOR
NUMBER TWO POSITION AT STANFORD
THE MEDICAL DIRECTOR OF SAN JOSE
FIRE DEPARTMENT AND REPRESENTING
THE EMERGING MEDICAL DIRECTORS
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA.
AND WE STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS
BECAUSE THE MORE TIME YOU GIVE
US THE MORALIZING SAFE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON ELIZABETH HAS
BEEN -- SOME BEHALF OF THE SANTA
CLARA COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND SUPPORT THANK
YOU.
AFFECT WORKERS FOR THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION ON THE SEVENTEEN
THOUSAND MEMBERS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AMYLIN MATHIS ON BEHALF OF
BEAUTY W. ASKED ME LOCAL THIRTY
NINE THIRTY IN SUPPORT.
OKAY THANK YOU.
OKAY I THINK THE I THINK IT'S
SELF EXPLANATORY OBVIOUSLY WE
HAVE TO HAVE NEW FUNDING SYSTEM.
IT'S REAL CLEAR -- WITH PEOPLE
DON'T USE NINE ONE ONE ANYMORE-AND ARE VERY LITTLE SOUL.
AND WE HAVE VERY FEW OF THE
OTHER LAND LINE SO -- IT'S CLEAR
THAT WE HAVE TO FIND ANOTHER
SOURCE OF REVENUE.
SO THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
PRESENTATION THANK YOU CHAIR.
ITEM ISSUE NUMBER.
TWO WHICH IS THE FUNDING FOR THE
STANDARDS AND TRAINING FOR THE
LOCAL CORRECTION A WHEN ASKED
YOU TO COME
[inaudible] FOR
FIFTY TWO HELLO.
YES PLEASE THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE AND
KATIE HOWARD THE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE BOARD OF STATE
AND COMMUNITY CORRECTIONS.
ON THE PROPOSAL IS OUTLINED HERE
IN YOUR AGENDA MY COLLEAGUE
YVONNE GARNER SHE'S THEY
DIVISION DIRECTOR OF OUR
STANDARDS AND TRAINING FOR
CORRECTIONS DIVISION HAS JUST A
COUPLE COMMENTS ON THE PROPOSAL
FOR YOU THANK YOU.
SO THIS REQUEST IS FOR A SIX
POINT TWO MILLION DOLLAR
INCREASE IN ONGOING FUNDING FOR
TRAINING FOR CORRECTIONS STAFF
WORKING IN PROBATION JUVENILE
FACILITIES AND JAILS.
THE FUNDING SUPPORTS THE
INCREASED TRAINING NEEDS AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL RESULTING FROM THE
MORE COMPLEX SUPER VISION
MEDICAL AND MENTAL HEALTH NEEDS
THAT REQUIRE THOSE OFFICERS TO
HAVE MORE AND BETTER TRAINING.
TO SAFELY AND EFFECTIVELY
PERFORM THEIR JOBS.
THE BOARD IS REQUIRED BY STATUTE
TO SET MINIMUM TRAINING
STANDARDS FOR CORRECTION STAFF
WE RECENTLY COMPLETED A
COMPREHENSIVE REVIEW OF THOSE
STANDARDS AND BROUGHT TOGETHER
MANY SUBJECT MATTER EXPERT WORK
GROUPS. TO ASSESS THE TRAINING
STANDARDS IDENTIFY GAPS AND MAKE
CHANGES WERE NECESSARY.
IN JANUARY THE BOARD APPROVED OF
THOSE NEW TRAINING SANDERS AND
THEY INCLUDE TRAINING IN
CRITICAL AREAS LIKE MENTAL
HEALTH.
DE ESCALATION TRAUMA INFORMED
CARE GENDER IDENTIFICATION AND
SEXUAL ABUSE AND ASSAULT.
BUT THESE TRAINING OR THESE
INCREASE TRAINING PARLIAMENTS
COME ON THE HEELS OF RECENT
REDUCTIONS THE PROGRAM SENDING
STEMMING FROM DECLINING REVENUES
IN THE STATE PENALTY FUND.
THIS REQUEST HELP TO BRIDGE THAT
GAP AND PROVIDE SOME ASSISTANCE
TO CORRECTIONS AGENCIES IN
MEETING THE STATE TRAINING
REQUIREMENTS.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONSIDERATION
OF THIS REQUEST THANK YOU ANY
COMMENTS FROM FINANCE.
HELLO AGAIN THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR CAITLYN O'NEILL WITH THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE.
I DESPITE RECENT DECLINES AND
FUNDING FOR THIS PROGRAM WE
FOUND THAT COMPLIANCE RATES WITH
THE TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ARE
QUITE HIGH. TO GIVE YOU AN
EXAMPLE IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
EIGHTEEN ONLY FORTY SEVEN OUT OF
THIRTY THREE THOUSAND ELIGIBLE
OFFICERS FAILED TO MEET THEIR
REQUIRED TRAINING AMOUNT UNDER
THE PROGRAM.
SO IT DOES APPEAR THAT PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES UNDER THE
EXISTING -- DISBURSEMENT FORMULA
AS HIS PROPOSED -- WOULD
ESSENTIALLY BE PAYING AGENCIES
MORE TO DO WHAT THEY'RE PRETTY
MUCH ALREADY DOING -- SO IT
DOESN'T APPEAR THAT THIS
PROPOSAL WOULD HAVE A MEANINGFUL
IMPACT ON TRAINING.
IN ADDITION THE BOARD DOESN'T
COLLECT DATA ON THE TYPES OF
TRAINING THAT OFFICERS ARE
PURSUING TO MEET THEIR ANNUAL
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS UNDER THE
PROGRAM.
SO IT'S NOT FULLY CLEAR AT THIS
TIME WHAT TYPES OF TRAINING ARE
BEING SUPPORTED BY THE PROGRAM.
SO WE RECOMMEND REJECTING THE
PROPOSAL GIVEN THAT IT DOESN'T
APPEAR THAT TO HAVE A THAT IT
WOULD HAVE A MEANINGFUL IMPACT
ON TRAINING.
I IN ADDITION WE RECOMMEND
DIRECTING THE BSE SEE TO BEGIN
COLLECTING DATA ON THE TYPES OF
TRAINING THAT OFFICERS ARE
COMPLETING AS A PART OF THE
PROGRAM.
BECAUSE WE THINK THAT THIS
INFORMATION WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR
THE LEGISLATURE TO HAVE WHEN
MAKING DECISIONS ON THIS PROGRAM
IN THE FUTURE.
HOWEVER IF THE IN THE MEANTIME
IF THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO
ACCOMPLISH A PARTICULAR GOAL IN
IN THE NEAR TERM AND FOR EXAMPLE
IN TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY IT
COULD.
CREATE A SEPARATE GRANT PROGRAM --
THAT IS MORE TARGETED AND
LIMITED TERM.
OKAY.
ANY OF QUESTIONS [inaudible]
COMMENTS.
DID YOU EVER SPONSOR OF THE ANY
OF THE ISSUES.
I WOULD JUST WANT TO CLARIFY WE
DO COLLECT DATA FROM EACH AND
EVERY PARTICIPATING AGENCY ON
PARTICIPATION WE ACTUALLY DO
MONITOR COMPLIANCE WITH THOSE
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS -- ANYONE
CAN EXPLAIN A LITTLE BIT MORE
ABOUT WHAT HOW WHAT THE OROVILLE
WHICH OF COURSE WE'RE HAPPY TO
SHARE WITH THE COMMITTEE RIGHT
AND THAT THE INFORMATION OF THE
DATE DATA THAT WAS BEING
REFERRED TO BY THE LA -- IS THAT
A TYPE OF A TRAINING THAT IS
USED TO COMPLETE THE ANNUAL
TRAINING REQUIREMENTS ONLY SEVEN
HOURLY TRAINING REQUIREMENT FOR
THAT.
AND WE LEAVE THE CONTENT TO BE
DETERMINED AT THE LOCAL LEVEL
BECAUSE THEY ARE MUCH MORE
PREPARED TO IDENTIFY SAID WITH
THE LOCAL PRIORITIES ARE THE
AGENCY REQUIREMENTS ARE.
AS WELL AS WITH THE INDIVIDUAL
NEEDS OF THE EMPLOYEE ARE.
SO WE ALLOW THOSE DECISIONS TO
BE MADE WE DO HAVE -- LOCALLY
AND WE DO HAVE A CERTIFICATION
SYSTEM SO WE COULD RUN QUERIES
BECAUSE EVERY COURSE HAS TO BE
CERTIFIED OF OUR SYSTEM TO
IDENTIFY WHERE IS TRAINING
OCCURRING ACROSS THE STATE WE
WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO TYPE BACK TO
THE INDIVIDUAL EMPLOYEE.
BUT WE CAN SEE SAID WHAT
TRAINING IS OCCURRING AND WE
REQUIRES PART OF THE
CERTIFICATION PROCESS THAT IT BE
RELATED TO THE JOB SO THEY HAVE
TO SORT OF BUILD THAT BRIDGE
BETWEEN THE TRAINING THAT THEY
RECEDING. TO MEET THE
REQUIREMENT AND THE NEEDS OF THE
JOB [inaudible]
OKAY.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU HELLO.
THE COMMENTS I'M SORRY.
PUBLIC COMMENTS WILL BE BRIEF
GOOD AFTERNOON MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS DANIEL SANCHEZ ON BEHALF
OF THE CHIEF PROBATION OFFICERS
OF CALIFORNIA AND VERY STRONG
SUPPORT -- PROBATION DOES OUR
CORN ANNUAL TRAINING THROUGH
THIS PROGRAM THIS REALLY IS A IN
OUR EYES KIND OF A RESTORATION --
A FUNDING FROM PREVIOUS YEARS AS
WE HAVE SEEN A SIGNIFICANT
CLIENT DECLINE -- OF SEVERAL
MILLION SO WE APPRECIATE THIS
COMMITTEES -- HISTORICAL WORK --
TO INVEST IN STC AND WE
CERTAINLY HOPE.
THAT AS DISCUSSIONS GO FOR IT
FOR THAT CONSIDERATION THIS YEAR
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
BUT I'M SURE NUMBERS COURCELLES
ALONG WE HAVE THE CALIFORNIA
STATE SHERIFFS ASSOCIATION HERE
IN SUPPORT.
OF THE INCREASE REQUIREMENTS FOR
TRAINING UNDER THE REEVALUATION
THAT BSE HAS DONE WITH THE HELP
OF PRACTITIONERS IN THE FIELD
ACROSS MANY DISCIPLINES -- AND
IN THE CONTEXT OF HAVING FUNDING
FOR ADDITIONAL TRAINING -- AS WE
SUPPORTER FOR POSTING AS THIS
COMMITTEE HAS SUPPORTED IN THE
PAST WERE APPRECIATIVE OF THE
OPPORTUNITY HERE IN SUPPORT
THANK YOU I THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER COMMENTS YES.
A CORE HONEY SURE IF YOU COUNTY
I WAS A MEMBER OF THE STEERING
COMMITTEE THAT.
ULTIMATELY DOT TO THESE WE WORK
HARD TO MAKE SURE THAT WE'RE
PROVIDING TRAINING THAT MEETS
THE NEEDS OF OUR POPULATION DAY
OR SUPPORT.
ALL RIGHT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
QUESTIONS OKAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU -- WE HAVE A
MEMBER WHO CAME IN -- GET A
RIGHT UNDER THE WIRE MISTER
GALLAGHER.
I DON'T KNOW I WAS I WAS
DEBATING IT.
BUT CAREFUL THIS ONE DOWN YOU
MIGHT AS WELL HERE.
OKAY -- WELL THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIRMAN YEAH I HAD A TO PRESENT
A BILL IN AND REVVING TAX AND
APPRECIATE YOU GIVING ME THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TO PRESENT ON THE
SIDE AND BOTTOM LINE WE'RE
ASKING FOR SEVEN POINT SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS.
AND THE OBJECTIVE HERE IS TO GET --
THIRTY EIGHT MEDICAL OR MENTAL
HEALTH BEDS IN THE BUTTE COUNTY
JAIL.
YOUR POST REALIGNMENT WE KNOW
HOW IMPORTANT -- THAT IS -- TO
PROVIDE THOSE THOSE RESOURCES --
THE BEAT CAN'T BE COUNTED
RECEIVED FORTY MILLION --
THROUGH THE THE SEC -- FUNDS --
BUT WITH THE CONSTRUCTION COSTS
THAT HAVE RISEN BOTH.
STATE WHY BUT ALSO BECAUSE THE
DISASTERS WE'VE HAD IT OR A BILL
IN THE CAMPFIRE.
ACOSTA INCREASE GREATLY SORE
ASKING FOR SOME ADDITIONAL
FUNDING TO MAKE SURE WE CAN
BUILD THESE.
BILL THESE MUCH NEEDED BEDS AND
I DO HAVE THE BE COUNTY SHERIFF --
HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT OKAY
THANK YOU.
MAN CHARM.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE THANK
YOU VERY MUCH IS ACTUALLY THE
PRIMARY SO I CAME HERE TO VISIT.
SO -- SINCE THE RATHER BILLS
THAT -- CERTAINLY -- WERE WORTHY
OF SUPPORT OF THIS ONE THOUGH OF
COURSE THERE DURING MY HEART IS
YOU KNOW WE RECEIVED FORTY
MILLION DOLLARS A FUNDING
THROUGH THE EIGHT SIXTY THREE
PROGRAM.
WITH A MATCH A FOUR POINT FOUR
MILLION WE WERE GONNA BILL TO
BUILD A FACILITY THAT MEETS THE
NEEDS OF THE INMATE POPULATION
THAT WE SERVE POST AB -- ONE
NINE MY COUNTY EMBRACED AB ONE
OH NINE WE WORKED HARD TO
IMPLEMENT PROGRAMS.
THAT WERE DESIGNED TO DEAL WITH
A DIFFERENT INMATE POPULATION --
DESIGNED TO DEAL WITH THEIR
COMMISSIONING NEEDS AND PROVIDE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS TO
ADDRESS THOSE NEEDS.
EVERYTHING WAS GOING ALONG QUITE
WELL UNTIL THE CAMPFIRE AND
AFTER THE CAMPFIRE -- WHEN WE
START OF WHAT LOOKING AT WHAT IT
WAS GONNA COST TO BUILD OF THE
FACILITY THAT WE NEED -- WE
REALIZE THAT WE WERE ABOUT SEVEN
POINT SEVEN MILLION DOLLARS
SHORT.
I'M TOLD THAT THE REASON FOR
THAT IS THE ANTICIPATED INCREASE
THE COST OF LABOR -- RIGHT NOW --
THERE IS VERY LITTLE IN THE WAY
OF HOUSING BUTTE COUNTY -- WE
DON'T HAVE MUCH LODGING AND
WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO BRING
CONSTRUCTION -- WORKERS FROM OUT
OF THE AREA -- I'M TOLD THAT IN
ORDER TO BE COMPETITIVE FOR A
HALF PAY ABOVE PREVAILING WAGE
AS WELL AS A PROVIDE HOUSING AND
SUBSISTENCE FOR THOSE WORKERS --
THAT'S THE ONE OF THE PRIMARY
REASON FOR THE INCREASE BUT
REGRETTABLY BUTTE COUNTY HAS
BEEN NO STRANGER -- TO NATURAL
DISASTERS THAT HAVE BECAUSE IN
US TO HAVE THESE KIND OF
PROBLEMS THE OROVILLE DAM
SPILLWAYS.
OF BEING ONE OF THEM THE BOTTOM
LINE IS AND I KNOW THAT YOU'RE
THAT KNOWS CAN LAY THE DAY I
WANNA MAKE IT FAST.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS -- WE'RE
LOOKING -- TO EXPANDER DEVELOP A
FACILITY IN BUTTE COUNTY THAT
MEETS THE NEEDS OF THE INMATE
POPULATION DAY AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THE HANDOUT THAT I PROVIDED
YOU -- THIS WOULD BE PAGE ONE
WAS IS THE PROPOSED UP --
PROJECT THAT -- WAS ULTIMATELY --
THE WE WE ALSO RECEIVE THE
FUNDING FOR IF YOU GO TO PAGE
TWO THIS ILLUSTRATES SOME OF THE
NEED.
A VERY VERY LIMITED IN TERMS OF
OUR ABILITY PROVIDE MEDICAL
MENTAL HEALTH -- TO INMATES A
VERY A FEW -- SPACES I ACTUALLY
ONLY HAVE THREE MEDICAL BEDS IN
A FACILITY THAT HAS SIX HUNDRED
FOURTEEN MEDICAL BEDS THIS IS
WOEFULLY INADEQUATE -- IF YOU
TURN TO PAGE THREE YOU'LL SEE
THE OLDER LINEAR STYLE JAIL
REGRETTABLY THIS IS THE AREA IN
THE JAIL WHERE WE HOUSE FEMALE
INMATES.
IT IS AN ERROR IT'S IT'S AN AREA
THAT WE NEED TO UPGRADE AND
ULTIMATELY YOU I'D LIKE TO DO
THAT WITH THE NINETY SIX BEDS WE
HAVE.
AND IF YOU TURN TO PAGE FOUR
YOU'LL SEE -- THE ONE FORMER --
CUSTODIAN CLOSET THAT WE TURNED
INTO A CLASSROOM PROVIDE
EVIDENCE BASED PROGRAMS FOR THE
INMATES WITHIN OUR FACILITY.
I'M HOPING TO BUILD A FACILITY
THAT ACTUALLY HAS ADEQUATE
PROGRAMMING SPACE -- WE
DESPERATELY NEED THE MONEY AND
AND I THINK BUT FOR THE
TRAGEDIES THAT WE FACE WITH
REGARDS TO MEET CASH THAT SHOULD
WE WOULDN'T BE IN THIS POSITION.
BUT IN ORDER MOVE FOR TO PROVIDE --
THE FACILITY THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS.
THE UNDERLYING CAUSE ACRYLIC
BEHAVIOR WITH THE EVIDENCE BASED
PROGRAMS.
WE'RE HERE WITH THIS VERY --
RESPECTFUL REQUEST.
ANY COMMENTS QUESTION FOR
MEMBERS.
FROM THE AUDIENCE YES SALINAS
POLICE ON BEHALF OF THE BIãU
COUNTY BOARD OF SUPERVISORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THE MONEY STAYS CORRECT THIS WAS
A PROPOSAL THIS WAS -- THIS IS
FUNDED AT TWELVE FORTY MILLION.
YEAH IT WAS FUNDED SB EIGHT
SIXTY THREE UP WE GOT FORTY
MILLION -- AND EVERYTHING WAS
GOING ALONG AND WE THOUGHT WE
WOULD BUILD A BILL TO BE ABLE TO
BUILD A FACILITY THAT AND THEN --
WITHIN STE INCREASED
CONSTRUCTION COSTS DUE PRIMARILY
TO THE CAMPFIRE -- WE ARE NOW
SHORT.
AND JEFFREY NOT BILL TO COMPLETE
THE PROJECT HOW MUCH IS BUILT
THUS FAR I MEAN NOT IN THE IN
THE PROCESS WE HAVE NOT IF YOU
AT THE PLANNING STAGE WHERE THE
PLANNING STAGE.
OKAY ALL RIGHT.
RATED BREAK GROUND.
THIS WEEK NEXT YEAR WE HAVE BEEN
SET BEHIND IN TERMS OF OUR
SCHEDULING AGAIN TO THE CAMPFIRE
NO THAT SOUNDS LIKE A BROKEN
RECORD AND I'M SORRY FOR THAT
BUT IT WAS.
A PRETTY DEVASTATING EVENT AND
CERTAINLY IS COSTA AN IMPACT US.
WHERE WHERE ARE YOU WERE YOU
HOUSING PEOPLE NOW SO CURRENTLY --
OUR JAIL IS WAS BASICALLY --
BUILT IN -- TWO DIFFERENT STAGES
I HAVE AN OLDER SECTION -- WHICH
IS THE NINETEEN SIXTY THREE ERA
JAIL THAT'S THE LINEAR STYLE
THAT YOU SEE THERE IN THE
PICTURE WITH THE BARS.
SO WE HAVE INMATES HOUSED IN
THERE WE ALSO HAVE A NINETEEN
NINETY FOUR MORE MODERN POPULAR
STYLE JAIL.
BUT NONE OF THESE FACILITIES
WERE DESIGNED TO HOLD PEOPLE --
IN A POST AB NINE L. AB ONE ON
WORLD AND PROVIDE A LONG TERM
ACCESS TO PROGRAMMING EVIDENCE
BASED PROGRAMS AS WELL AS DEAL
WITH THE MEDICAL MENTAL HEALTH
ISSUES THAT WE HAVE -- WITH
INMATES WERE SPINNING LINK THERE
TIMES IN COUNTY JAILS OKAY.
THANK YOU.
OKAY ANY OTHER COMMENTS
QUESTIONS. FOR QUICK AND AND IF
WE EVER.
ABLE TO GET USE THAT THE MONEY
WILL YOU HAVE THE STAFF TO DO
THE PROGRAMMING AND TO THE
REHABILITATION AND ESPECIALLY
THE MENTAL HEALTH STUFF THAT.
THAT THAT CAN BE KIND OF COSTLY
TO THAT IS THAT IS A FANTASTIC
QUESTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH
ACTUALLY WE WERE WORKING.
UP PRIOR TO ALL OF THIS.
TO SET ASIDE MONEY AND HAVE A
PLAN THAT WE COULD ULTIMATELY
ACCOMMODATE THAT THAT HASN'T
BEEN IMPACTED BY THE FIRE
BECAUSE WE'RE STILL THERE -- AND
WE'RE ALSO WORKING QUALQUER WITH
WITH THE COVERAGE THE HOSPITALS
WITH A. G. B. T. C. PROGRAM --
TO HELP RESTORE A COMPETENCY AND
WE'D LIKE TO SEE THAT CONTINUED
WITH A FACILITY THAT WAS MORE
CONDUCIVE TO THOSE EFFORTS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THANK YOU
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I THINK
WE'VE HEARD EVERYONE WHO'S HERE
I'M SORRY -- I DON'T THINK
MISTER BONTA IS HERE NO HE'S NOT
SO WE'VE HEARD ALL THE MEMBERS.
OF WHO HAD.
THE REQUEST IF THAT BEING THE
CASE -- WE ARE ADJOURNED THANK
YOU VERY MUCH.
FOR COMING